some people treat their dogs like a
slave you notice it so I went to the
park this morning to get a little bit of
heat a little free heat from the
sunshine you know a little bit of that
vitamin D straight from the vitamin G OD
you feel me I'm talking straight off the
head of the Lord the sky and just catch
that free heat right in my face and net
and I went over there and I was just
sitting in the in the grass making me a
little gratitude list and doing a couple
of outings and stuff on the UM on one of
those legal pads you know and this man
heard this old man he's like char he
goes Charlie got over ere so Charlie got
out of her hair and I thought it was too
you know kind of drug-induced or you
know drug induced homosexual men doing a
you know splitting up a you know a gram
or a vial of uh vial of speed but then I
look over in this man who I'll be honest
this man looked like Doody bro this man
looked like just man just real just just
duty duty and he's yelling at this dog
because the dog smelled something or saw
it is in the dog he's over there he's
investigating you know he might have a
little bit of hounding him or a little
bit of uh investigator gadget or
whatever that guy's name was remember
that show but the the dog he's you know
he's sniffing on an orange peel or doing
something you know we're smelling um you
know a part needle or something or
whatever and a man's like shards get all
this yelling at him
and Charlie first of all Charlie was way
healthier this man looked like just
first of all looked like somebody has
shaved his whole body with like a 1 or
like a 1 and a half he had a fade like
on his arms shoulders everything crate
just real bristly looking dude kind of
guy he looked like he was like a pipe
cleaner you know what a member of pipe
cleaners remember in school sometime if
he was one of the weirdo kids and they
at the art class they would give you
these pipe cleaners and say hey do
something with this and you'd be like
what do I do it it by God we don't
notice do something we hoping you
graduate soon cuz nobody could stand you
you know and um and yet this dude young
thinking man this dog and then the so
then the dog comes over by me and now
I'm kind of pissed cuz I'm sitting there
trying to do a little bit of um legal
work or whatever you know right and
stuff and drawing and this man's Charlie
leave him alone I said dude I said
Charlie mess with me man
I said you messing with me by yelling
you're messing with everybody sir and
[ __ ] it just I don't know man and the
dog went over to him and I just felt
like I don't know when Charlie left dude
I felt like damn bro Charlie don't wanna
be with that man and that man treats him
bad I saw I felt dude so but yeah
Charlie was like a big dog and I'll be
honest I slipped on a piece of nicorette
so Charlie [ __ ] get that hit from
Daddy right there so that guy can kiss
my ass bruh what I'm saying is you can't
your dog is not a slave he doesn't work
for you ok you can't you know say this
dude is Charlie get in the house no ham
hocks Charlie nothing for you you can't
be like that to an animal you got to
treat an animal a little bit kinder I
think but I don't know I don't know
their backstory this [ __ ] just made me
mad I don't see a lot of animals and
stuff so in here in Los Angeles so it
just made me kind of a kind of upset
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw
I mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch could be way better what
if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one